hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the end of Disney I don't
mean the literal end of Disney that
would be kind of sad we don't need to
worry about that because we're playing
five nights at Treasure Island now if
you guys remember way back when five
nights at Freddy's was first released
there was a game called five nights of
Treasure Island it was one of the first
five nights at Freddy's fan games that I
ever played if not the first and I saw
this game on gamejolt and I kind of have
a policy against five nights at Freddy's
fan games but the developer said that
this was his last attempt at making a
five night to Treasure Island game and
he wanted to finish it off strong so I
thought it'd be kind of cool to play
this game to see how far along number
one the developer has come and to kind
of reminisce about the time after five
nights at Freddy's and how that kind of
changed a whole bunch of [ __ ] so he
decided to come back to Treasure Island
how Pleasant why though the place is
collapsing the suits are hell bound and
it's just a train wreck okay if you want
to survive here's the drill in place of
shutting the cameras off two buttons
have been installed on your desk press
one if something comes in to shock it in
order to get out charge up the
generators on the camera before 6:00
a.m. so to win I have to do something
before the time runs out is that what
I'm told here and then people are gonna
come by and I'm gonna stab them with a
cattle prod Oh
oh I do remember this I totally remember
this oh wow hi melty face Mickey oh hey
there hi buddy
oh I remember oh I never know what are
you is that rabbit oh there's a rabbit I
forget the name of the rabbit oh hi is
that foxy just plain old Fox here's that
goofy oh man I actually legitimately
remember this seems you have seen better
days than this but it's kind of
interesting to see how far it's come
because that's almost been if not
exactly two years from now which is kind
of incredible and I don't know why I'm
getting errors on my buttons not able to
do anything here maybe I'm just not
supposed to be able to do anything at
all fact I don't even know why I came
here personal charge generator am i
doing it I think I am so do I just got
it do I just hold this about die hard I
about dying are weird ways about the
killed about get killed I did it yeah I
think I do
oh the Jenner is for each individual
camera oh jeez
I can't I hear anything I thought this
was loud but there it is what is that
okay alright I can hear that now
that's for damn definitely sure so I
gotta charge all the generators that's
what I'm supposed to be able to gather
you want to see my head come off hey
[ __ ] you buddy that's my head alrighty
then oh is that supposed to be me
have I been ripped from my skin oh boy
Oh buddy boo well alright now I know
what I need to do yeah oh god why that
face little so yeah it's just kind of
interesting to see how far along it's
come and still be able to get scared by
it because I think for some reason this
one really resonated with people one
because Disney characters in all of you
all that jazz but - it's kind of a silly
concept in all reality the juxtaposition
of Disney's normally superbly happy
lovely lovely lovely time I wonder what
would happen if I just get everything
close to being done and then swap them
all out so if I can just do that I think
it's gonna be pretty difficult to do now
I definitely hear that music I don't
know if I broke something before and it
wasn't able to hear it but now I
definitely do was that I hear something
no okay
so twelve I am if I can just get through
the first night I'm gonna consider this
a victory I don't even know if I'm I'll
be able to do that here that here some
Oh unless that's his music as if it is
good God all right
I heard that hi I heard a deep rumble in
my tumbly
okay I'm gonna go then how about
assuming everything's I heard that as
well
I keep hearing deep rumbly bum Blees I'm
assuming that the rumbly bum believes is
badly Radley I'm or die Lee Wylie let's
like you know know y'all never back out
unzips happen i'm zappy weapon nobody's
gonna give me when i'm sap tastic close
there oh hey you're getting awfully
close to me aren't you aren't you yeah
Gimli dude don't move just gonna move
don't [ __ ] move I'm gonna come back
to you
Suzy's a pure ice apple zap um
zabi wampum a my zip zapping turn turn
turn turn turn turn
Jordan turns hurtin i don''t oh [ __ ]
Jordan does mm family happy happy happy
anybody want to give me a zip tab
Zebedee whap oh don't tell me I get oh
[ __ ] don't tell me I got to actually
survive oh [ __ ] hey yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] it up
and not Donald right [ __ ] god damn it
it's this is generators isn't it
[ __ ] there's nothing left of Cheers I
just got to survive and mash my sappy
buttons maybe I'm just addicted to it
and I like the feel of being
electrocuted
hi oh can I could I could I as a bum
okay all right then
I didn't see you last time so I'm
assuming that happened before and I
didn't see it maybe I shouldn't just be
whaling on my buttons like this guy have
some self-control when it comes to
button mashing I just can't wait until I
hear Goofy's oh I mean it's a admittedly
it is only night one so admittedly I
should be able to do this without too
much trouble don't do that don't do that
so I don't know where he is but don't
kill me
zip yeah Jimmy but I think I'm okay
maybe I don't know I didn't see him up
here but I see a distinct Mickey ear
pattern in that I did it hey I'm the
winner
I've done something with my life I've
accomplished the Lord house in those it
oh come on man
oh no oh wait no I can't do night -
that's right you just continue or I
thought you would have rolled into it
okay how well you made it tonight -
Congrats
tonight the suit if Oswald becomes
active starting in the storage room get
rid of him the same way with the
inverted Mickey one Oh same for the
melted Mickey also have Donald head from
character prep wanna peers in your
office he will disable the buttons so
hide under the desk then make him go
away
once again charge up the generators to
survive and good luck well it seems like
way more complicated than last night why
do you gotta be such a douche
all righty then here we go yes something
about bad stuff happen I don't know
where Donald's head's gonna come into
play here but mmm probably gonna be good
I gotta admit the ambience music whoa
no okay the ambience music I like that
it's very good very good very good
good thing I'm two days from retirement
also again I want to ponder why am i
back here why did I come in - oh no babe
in place where everything is death and
destruction and goofy wants to goof me
in the goof hole and everything's gonna
be bad then Donald wants to know Donald
wants me to literally [ __ ] a duck now
was that what was that was there
anything I big bubble on baby
a bubble on a buhbuh buhbuh buhbuh
buhbuh blowing I didn't do anything what
the hook was that are you saying to me
is it goofy the Donald says all fall I
got three excuse me pardon me what do
you say I don't know I don't know no no
no you don't know you do not hey Oswald
how you doing
oh you're nearby can't believe I forgot
your name very sorry about that Oswald
if you could stop staring at me while
I'm charging this don't be greatly
appreciated oh you're gonna keep looking
at me they're noisy because I'm dumb
[ __ ] [ __ ]
only dicks
oh god no okay
I think I think it's good I'm gonna get
all the generators
now zip is a bit about I think I'm good
let's have some secrets happening over
here
Oswald's back whose head is this Oh
heads gone huh oh no it they're just
moved
oh that's Mickey oh good I was looking
for a friend
oh no heavens no hell's just this okay
y-you do there was that I saw that I saw
that over there you can't hide Tim I saw
you in the darkness man good old goof
boys still hiding away there I know if
anything's gonna happen goofball comes
out maybe deaf maybe escort to the
heaven and the hell if I have a moment
to actually talk and not panic I want to
say that this game is actually made way
better than the original I would have to
say who disturbs the dead me my name is
markiplier a professional dead disturber
oh hey nice giggles there I mean is
there another one now one went with last
incident but I'm funny feeling the night
three is gonna be a son of a [ __ ]
night three what do you get for me the
first two were easy I only died once and
that's when I didn't know what I was
doing so what have you got for me
tonight is mainly the same safe for the
grayscale Mickey costume becoming active
alongside or ten SIA Oswald's girlfriend
from the cartoons but you'll be doing
something big after 6:00 a.m. go to the
pirate caverns it's down the meat
freezer in there you may find something
that will help you I heard theories the
third floor is there which is strange as
there is only to go see if that's true
well I don't know who to believe the guy
that told me there are three or the guy
that told me there were only two Oh way
it's a same person yo how'd it go to the
third floor that is an excellent
question and why is there a meat freezer
in Treasure Island
all excellent questions okay sorry sorry
hi okay good okay you went away whoever
that was don't know who that was it
might have been all's Wald or or ten SIA
by the way I want to mention I like this
mechanic
I like the mechanic of having to do
something in every camera keeps me
moving around which is kind of nice
something that I haven't seen in a lot
of fun a fan games or the main games
themselves it's it's a simple activity
and it's not a lot it's akin to the
music box from five nights at Freddy's
dead oh how about I what it allows me to
what did I do
show my face after what I've done what
did I do
I was just me I barely even finished the
first game I think it was a demo when I
played it that's I can hello hi hello
everybody
[ __ ] the dwarfs the tubes are you
talking about the youtubes oh boy
Oswald's up next oh boy all souls here
Jesus
jiminy Christmas they are quick today oh
boy knows here is engine
no booze ghee okay how do I get to the
meat freezer well that's how a good
sound I like that sound absolutely the
opposite of good I mean a lot I mean I
don't like it I mean I hate it
I mean it's so worst I mean it's kind of
cool I guess what the [ __ ] is happening
I don't even know how to hide outta my
desk
oh [ __ ] I'm owed RNAi hi how do I go to
the meat freezer Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] goofy
I got goofed I got goofed all over I got
goof juice all over me alright so anyway
that's all I'm gonna play for this game
I don't think I'm gonna do a full play
through this but it's really well made I
mean five nights at Freddy's fan games
they've been making them for about two
years now so it's hard to get some
innovation out of it but I like it I
like the concept it's got some heart and
soul to it it's got some depth to the
story it's got reminiscent of the old
one which is kind of nice have the
connective tissue be there but alas I
don't think I'm gonna play a full
version of this game but I do applaud
the works of the developer photo- Mickey
and the 30 odd dev team so thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this let me know what you
thought of it down in the comments below
and if you want to see the original that
I played I'll put that in the
description as well features a little
young meet about two years ago that it
that me add a boy that boy that me thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next video